وفد علي د حجر ح بطلش من بيتي هذا بيتي
اهمت فيه وحياتي عشت هنا وبدي اموت ه ق
اللي بيطلع من ب من بيت هذا جبان ولا
يساوي شيء في حياتي في نظري هذه ارضي وطني
جدي هان عاش وابوي عاش وانا بعيش وابني
برضه حيعيش ه في هذا الوطن ان شاء الله
نتمنى لكم الخير والتوفيق قدش عمرك يا عم
عمري بالضبط مواليد الارعين ما شاء الله
اه والحمد لله صامد في بلدي وفي ديني وفي
وطني والله يكتبكم السلامي جميع طب مين
كانت اقوى الحرب ولا حرب 67 اه 67 انا حظت
48 ال 56 67 والحروب الصغيره هذه وحرب هذا
اصعب شرسه حرب شفته في حياتي الحرب هذا
لانهم جايمين ناس مجرمين ذئاب هدوا البيت
قتلوا الاطفال رمل النساء لو دخلت الدبابه
لهان ايش بدك تعمل لا حول ولا قوه الا
بالله اذا بموت موت شهيد ايش هذا الوطن
اصيب هذا الوطن ان شاء الله اني انا بموت
شهيد في وطني في داري افضل ما اكون اروح
على المدارس واروح على اي مكان انا مواليد
في هذا المكان مواليد في جبال وحم واعيش
في جبال واموت في ال جبال ان شاء
الله